but they kept offering you increasingly  large sums of money to go away didn't  they you're right it went up to about  265 000 not to appear in the field right  to stay away to get off my lawn boy but  what what they didn't count on is  when a person  hasn't had that type of money  they really don't miss it in other words  if you haven't ridden in a Rolls-Royce  you don't mind bouncing around in a  Volkswagen it was you don't have that  frame of reference but more than that I  knew that if I sold it even for five  hundred thousand dollars I knew that  after the money was gone I would become  very bitter for having sold out because  my one love was to at least fail on my  own terms I wanted to see if I could act  because all these bid parts that you're  talking about you really couldn't say  this kid had Talent OR it was just a big  fake